islam was founded
um
by a man
who
[Music]
was it was founded in a context
muslims in norway are now establishing a
masjid and tawa center to enhance the
norwegian dawah if you donate to the
scores you will insha allah reap the
rewards of thousands of muslims coming
back to islam and many of those who
become dwight and invite to islam so
click the link and donate now and share
the video for extra rewards
how are you guys doing now many of you
already know that the opposing views
episode that i done with one iron mcgann
who refers to herself as iron hersey
ally because she is a liar and she has
been lying to the dutch parliament and
she's been lying to
the public about islam and what it
entails and she is an ignoramus an
academic charlatan an obsequious woman a
right-wing apple polisher
that individual has now quite frankly
been exposed if you go and watch that
video you i think you'll agree with me
um not many people even from the other
side let's say can disagree with that
but i wanted to just point on some of
the things because obviously in that
uh opposing views a format i couldn't i
didn't have access to to her responses
and she did not have access to my
responses so there are some things i
wanted to bring
uh to respond to and not that she
deserves a response because i think for
all intents and purposes anyone with a
shred of integrity and maybe an iota of
sincerity will know that her academic
career if she ever had one in the first
place
is over now with all due respect or none
due to her
this individual actually by the way i
couldn't read this out in the opposing
views for much i should give you a taste
of what kind of individual she is this
is something she mentions in one of her
books
she mentions and i quote
she was talking about christian churches
she says but i think christian church
should begin dawa look how she has
riddle and anger
subhanallah resentment towards the tawa
the propagation of islam and the muslim
people she goes but i think christian
church should begin douwa exactly as
islam does
you need to compete because you can be
as powerful you can be a powerful tool
to reverse islamization she states yeah
you should start with muslim
neighborhoods in rome
she's talking to a priest here and she
says
europe is sleepwalking into disaster
cultural ideological and political
disaster because the authorities of the
church have neglected the immigrant
ghettos she states the churches could go
into muslim communities provide services
just as the radical muslims do build new
catholic schools hospitals communities
community centers just like the ones
that were such a civilizing force under
colonialism in africa
this person is not just an apostate from
islam this person
is the equivalent of the the monster
uncle tom no aunt jemima where the hell
the equivalent uncle tommy is the
monstrous
uh you know uncle tom that she is a
colonized colonialism in africa she's an
apostate from african identity
itself
not just islam
but not just that and i've mentioned
this and alluded to it but i wanted to
give you clarity and proof because i did
mention it in the discussion but i
wanted to mention it once more look what
she says about islam in her book one of
her main books this is printed
this is printed
she states a key problem for islam today
can be summarized in three simplifying
sentences christians worship a man made
divine
jews worship a book
and muslims worship both
she doesn't know the basics of islam
look at what she says here in her book
infidel i've read her books
rubbish
books they are
she goes on her tour so she's talking
about a particular film that was
released on hotel
is written the opening verse of the
quran the surat al-fatiha so she refers
to an entire chapter as a verse she
doesn't know the basics and she
continues by the way there's other
things like this where she talks about
hadith like for example
or the jannah is under the feet of the
mother she says the verse of the quran
she does not know how to differentiate a
verse from a chapter
at the verse of the quran
and
this person is meant to be the scholar
that is telling us and teaching us about
islam this is meant to be the scholar
joe rogan and jordan pearson and these
individuals they're putting her on
i want to show you the extent of her
ignorance by just letting her answer a
simple gcse re type question that she
stutters i i thought that this was in
many ways the most telling part of the
entire opposing views segment let's take
a let's take a look at how she answers a
very simple question what the
differences of islam and christianity
are let's take a look what do you think
the primary differences are that you've
seen between islam and christianity
the primary differences
primary differences yeah
well i think
the the primary and probably the most
well-known differences is islam was
founded
by a man
who
was it was founded in a context
that was tribal
very parochial very small
and the man who founded islam
turned it into an empire so i'm really
sorry to say this but this academic
charlatan
in addition to saying
she's not knowing the basics clearly
identified by her printed works and her
public
display or presentations
she
in addition to that continues
lying to the public and telling people
or insinuating that islam
uh has a force of bleak or forced
convert narrative that we force people
to become muslims let's take a look at
what she states trying to get non-muslim
societies to adopt islam either through
persuasion or through force or through
both of those means now this she keeps
mentioning this
it's as if she has not mentioned or she
has not read and she clearly has
actually because i've seen it in her one
of her books she mentions it
the verse
there is no compulsion in religion
even arnold walker
who wrote the book proselytizing oh
sorry the preaching of islam an
orientalist doesn't take this view that
islam was spread by the sword in the
sense that people were forced to become
muslims on mass
in in where islam conquered land
and even if there were times in places
in the islamic history where that did
takes place it clearly goes against
the verse which is
2 256 in surah baqara la iqra fadin
there's no compulsion in religion so she
keeps mentioning this point
and to to make islam look like a
monstrous religion
or she in fact is a monstrous liar
and i will say something else
that she and i've mentioned this before
and i'll emphasize the point again was
the same individual that anders breivik
the individual who responds who was
responsible for killing 77
individuals majority of them were
non-muslims in norway in one of the most
prolific crimes in the last hundred
years
that individual dedicated an entire
chapter to iron mcgann iron hershey
mcgann an entire chapter he dedicated
praising her saying that she should have
won the nobel peace prize
and that she that her views are quite
commensurate with his and you know
saying good words about her clearly
inspired
and influenced by her
right wing fascistic narratives
this is an individual who killed white
liberal people to put it crudely white
liberal people you can see the extent to
which her drivel
can lead to actual impact on the ground
she's talking about islam
scapegoating it maybe projecting her own
kind of maliciousness
onto it malignancy
and malevolence
the individual that
that is iron mcgann really has no
credentials to talk about these things
as we mentioned in the first place
and then again she makes a series of
claims about women's rights most of
which are nonsense claims
now this is something she did mention in
some of her books but she keeps saying
it's almost impossible for a muslim
woman to get a divorce
compared to what into what system like
for example we'll talk about other
religions
whose system is easier for it to be to
get a divorce is it easier for a muslim
man a woman to get a divorce or is it
easier for an orthodox jewish woman who
has to get the get in fact that system
is much more difficult for a woman to
get a divorce the get
in some circles you you cannot even get
a woman cannot even get a divorce
without the husband's
consent
well about catholicism for the longest
of time divorce was prohibited
completely and she was singing the
praises of christianity whereas in
clearly in islam there is such a thing
as fasc where a woman can get a divorce
even without the consent of her husband
hadith
you know if it wasn't for a woman came
to the prophet said it had it not been
for the fear of allah would have spat in
his face and then he got them separated
meaning without his permission so this
kind of thing is clearly in islam so
once again how exaggerated comically
exaggerated claims which are in fact
not factual
are intended for the sole purpose of
maligning islam and she has not quoted a
single source throughout the whole video
i don't think in the entire video that
she's quoted a single source not even
one
from the primary text of islam let alone
academic resources and so on so she's
absolutely
lost
and then she mentions that women are
confined to the house well of course
that's not true at all and the only
verse that can be used let me help her
out a little bit is the views
which talks to the prophet's wives and
says and stay in your homes
and it can also be read
by the way which means
which means have sakina have tranquility
in your homes even with them because we
know that the prophet's wives they left
their homes
they left the homes they went and done
things i mean they led wars in the case
of aisha not to say that all of that was
in her own interest according to her own
testimonies but they definitely stayed
out of the house but you've got all
kinds of pro
so commandments on in islam for example
do not prevent the woman slaves of allah
from going to the masjids what if a
woman wants to go and see her parents
the vast majority of islam says
and no one can stop her from doing that
and in fact the husband must facilitate
such a thing what if she has to go for
another reason
there's nothing to say a woman must stay
in the house in this house and be
trapped like a prisoner in islam there's
no such thing
and so that's something else which she
exaggerates and lies about but there's a
series of claims that i'm looking at
right here which are to be honest with
you too numerous to mention by what i
will and to be honest too
comical in the first place something
that even the most basic student of
knowledge will be able to dismiss
so instead of doing all of that i will
just leave you with one thought this
person has been exposed
exposed and if you have a shred an iota
of academic integrity
or sincerity in your heart in your mind
especially if you are non-muslim
watching this you cannot
you cannot take this kind of narrative
seriously especially coming from this
kind of person
and if you really want to know about
islam then you have to go to the sources
directly read it for yourself the quran
has been trying the meanings of
translations of the quran have been have
been translated many places for free you
can go quran.com you'll find a
translation of the quran just go to the
sources yourself go to the muslim
community it's high time we start
educating people about the religion of
islam and enough is enough
muslims in norway are now establishing a
messaging and dawa center to enhance the
norwegian tawa if you donate to the
schools you will ensure allah reap the
rewards of thousands of muslims coming
back to islam and many of those who
become dwight and invite to islam so
click the link and donate now and share
the video for extra rewards